[Music]
early here at Pebble Beach and joined by
some royalty Nick Faldo sir Nick Faldo
who's joined us
I think he's regretting getting up Nick
early demoting a coffee after that he
was analyzing our golf swings there you
know I I'm sure there's the backup
singing this piece of the dance at Dan
Tana's yes the Dennis we talked to
Jordan speith yesterday I said part of
being a pro is being able to say
something nice when you are in a program
because you're gonna steal oh yeah yeah
like you'll you'll lie to the to the
amateur won't you about the swing
absolutely oh that's the most important
thing yeah
now I used to the best bit was they
would stand up and hit it straight in
the trees straight right into your honor
and I would say good shot to the guy's
eyes I guess that's exactly where you're
aiming and that's the number for me
that's the number one problem amateur
golfers they cannot aim in the right but
apart from kissing their needs on the
downswing
norm its alignment is a major problem
yeah you were saying that Seton kisses
his knees so he's bent over too far
hunters backswing yeah they would kept
going down and yeah I mean it was it was
it was interesting there you go see good
no yeah yeah just remember don't kiss
your knees don't catch you need did you
ever play in a program where the
amateurs thought that he could beat you
regularly oh yeah man many a time it
will now drive you and then the other
day they out drive you out they want
that magic moment which is fun which is
which is great we come as a dinner story
we do get some great stories I mean now
you've gone on to that I just wonderful
gentleman moons ago is up there in some
Michigan I think up there and we went
out you know early morning and this chat
was at 80 years old is just absolutely
true as I said I've got it now you've
reminded me to down the first he can't
you know he takes an 8 he tops it shanks
it also he talked about it so I saw for
once in my life be nice to them you know
to give them a lesson so I said can you
get your weight over a little bit on
your batches well I've had hip
replacement done it's a little chilly
this morning I can't get the wait hours
all right ok I said well if you can't do
that then you've got to get you try and
get your left shoulder a little
it round a bit more and he honestly said
well I've got a new Tigers and um the
left shoulder put in ice and I said sir
so ice again it's a [ __ ] you can't get
will problem well an absolute mustard
he's keep your eyes on the book he says
what I picked up the wrong glass this
morning and I've got the back so I said
apart from that everything's okay his
pardon body so yeah so we do get we do
get some amazing shots we have hit we
have seen guys and you remember him it
was a bait he'll go to the full swing
with a 3-wood and it drove the ball into
the ground and it will popped out and
finishing you're behind it and ice cream
and god that's fantastic I'm never
feeling that before the cup anyway sir
Nick Faldo joining us here at Pebble
Beach what is about this place that
makes this magical this is the next up
to heaven is nothing this is
unbelievable and the scenery the Golf
Course is a fantastic man normally when
we get that so that's we blacked out as
you've probably seen on TV last four or
five years it's an unbeliever every
year's got better but we may have a
couple of rough days here but even when
it's rough you still it's something
about it you know I always come up early
we come up here in Mundy's it's one of
the few weeks well actually come in and
enjoy these three days prior to night so
I start work today and and then the
golf's great that come is great to bump
into different celebs and what have is
really cool who are you played with
though that night makes you nervous but
you know like were you know is really
cool I first came the dear old Jim
Mahoney
I laid here way back I think it's like
my name in 1983 was my first time here
and we're in the parties we've got Glen
Campbell so that was very cool I'm
playing with oh my goodness also Jack
Lemmon of course with Peter Jacobs out
that through that ear of trying to get
Jack across the line couldn't make the
cut no and that was what I don't know if
it was that year but I remember you know
the story about jacket the first pole
when he
his t-shirt off the first win in the
right rough and he went into so guys I
just need to pick a restroom break you
know that story waiting Italy and he's
sitting and then his lady comes in the
room he's sitting in the wrong room
if he falls sideways into through the
sliding doors didn't he did he get up
into somebody's room Oh sorting on any
gunplay that's the best of fun it is it
is celebrities embrace it and it's James
gon play me James gonna goes down that's
first it at spike I say hit you three
wooden 3-wood over his knee and I
thinking okay it's going to be a
relaxing day what was it like the first
time you played with Nicolas big at Wow
well you know he was my introduction and
inspiration I watched the Masters in 71
that's all right I want to be a golfer
let's try best try golf that's how it
all started and see first time I play
worms you know would have been we've
been that Ryder Cup 77 running a six
years later after studying the game of
golf I'm playing against jack in the
right Achilles every seven Ryder Cup and
I never forget because I was long in
those days I had a licorice stick nobody
just invented out our diely I just
invented the graphite shaft and I hit
this thing out that the fourth hole and
I driven it I tell it I played twenty
yards by Jack who's actually sir he's I
don't upset 20 yards past Jack I'm
standing there looking forward at the
green thinking don't look back up and I
could feel his eyes burning in the back
of my neck and I'm not actually a
mechanic anyway with my partner produced
house we beat them we beat Jackson Ray
Floyd on the 17th green two and one so
you imagine that as my my kind of intro
and and my great my favorite story is
that so I started in 71 and in 73 1973
my dad took me to true to my very first
open and I loved it because I spent my
time on the practice ground and I just
watched the guys practice of all I
wanted I was soaking up all these
different videos synced all these
different tempos new Jack Connelly and
Gary and Trevino and Miller and why
scoffs okay
but anyway so I go to our porta-johns
which is called toilets back in Britain
you know I'd be fing obese and Jack
jumped over the fence right from the
hotel he's staying at the Royal the
hotel jumps over the fence to get to the
range to avoid the crowd just me and
Jack and he goes in and to the restroom
and cuz he's in there just him I stood
out there in shock and he comes out I
didn't shake his hand
buddy and I disappeared and cuz I'm 16
so what do I do so go in there and what
does a 16 year old boy do i whittled
everywhere all the way around to say
I've got wiggled with Jennifer
so I tell Jack this story now 40 years
later any COO is gone what he's wiggling
nervous a little bit so that's that was
my first intro to giant you know so
that's pretty cool and you somehow got
knighted with stories like oh yeah that
they didn't hear that bit yeah for
services to golf yeah what is knighthood
get you in England like you get anything
that way from a nice title yeah they
well it they got great service of
Windsor Carter you send your suit of
armor in and they NAB and they will
polish it for you hi-yah excuse cool you
might get an odd read you know odd
restaurant you might manage to get a
table and they're absolutely jam-packed
do you have the Queen's number do I have
the Queen's number now I actually don't
know I one doesn't have the Queen oh
they don't
oh no what about Prince Harry or
presenter I used to play a lot of golf
with Princess oh you're even way but
yeah moons ago I was very with the place
and George's he was very sweet you bet
we could actually just call him unseat
him
let's whizz out and go and play a few
holes and yeah we should go and play
nine and what have you and so that was
that was very cool I don't we've talked
about this and I always appreciate your
honesty you know with Tiger Woods with
where he is down yeah and I was watching
from him a couple of weeks ago he looked
like an old 41 year old man
unfortunately hits I did a piece we did
we warmed the season up for CBS you know
we were a conference call and I
basically said it's freeze - now
number one the back is good it's all
physical for me if he's back he is good
he can go and play he can enjoy himself
and every day he'll finish productive
number two the back type starts to
tighten up but he does have a plan B he
there's a deep fun he has another way of
playing I'm making the score and steal
things okay so maybe I can get through
this
and unfortunately Plan C was not really
a plan is it a third opportunity you
know things tighten up and it's not good
and he arrived at Torrey Pines we
watched him warm up and wow it's the
same he stood on the range and was
aiming for a perfect fade absolutely
perfect I'm thinking great aiming down
the left there's all his lines a great
so then he's starting the driver over
there on that corner so get me that
almost like a thirty degree difference
and so he watched in the first
application and I have to say
unfortunately he's back that's starting
to tighten up and he and it limits him
he has to compensate and everybody's
analyzing the swing but I say there's no
point because he was then he ran and ran
off to Dubai and you could see the back
tightens up again I effect everything so
unless he can unless he can find a way
to physically be able to play golf
productively and really enjoy himself
doing it too he actually feels like it's
going to be a I don't know how he's
going to give her him a table viously
looks in the mirror he knows honestly
where his back is and how how limited he
is with it can he think his way around a
golf course like that he's limited but
now he nice to is unfortunately limited
in RIT we also talked about you know
your go-to shot yeah other thing and you
can see he has to stand up on it and has
to flip it to hit this draw which is and
I actually felt strong enough I'm
average I went up to him on Friday
morning after him Torrey Pines and I
said the two swings you made down 11 and
16 were fantastic which will fade with a
4-iron or threa I said please consider
using toes a bit more I know my audience
with him about five seconds of it just
consider that but I think physically
he's limited in he had and anyone any
quote came out he's swinging you know
around the plane or to avoid the pain
which is not good which is yeah
as you know it's a real fishing people
don't give credit to golfers it's a
serious physical test to come and play
72 holes and compete the way these guys
competing did he take your advice I mean
how is that one yeah I feel if somebody
did that to you
well I always yeah you're right baby I
would like to think if somebody of a
similar I mean I bleed with our majors
we would beamers on a similar not on
this equal ever know people will go
crazy each got anything I got sick so
who the hell am I to talk to a guy who's
got 14 but I love I was watching
what I thought was amazed watching
macula Nikon I was great is me plant a
is the best and he is critiquing Roger
Federer at 10 years ago when Rogers
complied tiger completely dominant now I
see the positives in that I go in that
fantastic II he can see something that
can make Roger Federer's backhand better
other people would say who the hell do
you think you are McEnroe telling Rogers
forget me yeah so I think I know what
I'm talking about with the ghosts when I
spin out of plays head stuff and that's
why I was trying to save you could just
stick with that that swing was great I'm
at least I was talking old or positive
that swing is great the other one not so
sure of this having go down that road
but so if you could play with a fade but
then I the first question should have
been can you physically fade the ball
all day long I mean that is the next
question we appreciate you stopping by
hopefully we haven't you know burned
that in your memory of what our golf
swings are not to go up a life we would
you okay would you during the commercial
break just give us like a little simple
what Nick Faldo would be hitting we have
the globe the AT&T glow behind us yes
just to show us what it's like you want
me to hit a few now yeah we'll take a
break we'll come back and you uh you
show us hell and I'll get your guard eat
or to my go swing like you will nightly
and don't kiss your knees Nick Faldo be
on the call with Jim Nantz obviously on
CBS and you're working later on today of
golf channeling oh we're on it we're
we're on 11:00 this morning can we moved
tee times up to hope your boy what is it
that skull is pretty too all Mahalo
over there that look at that why you
come to Pebble Beach
that is gorgeous isn't it unbelievable
an unfortunate means red sky in the
morning if the Shepards warning so it's
going to be horrendous today but perform
at it it looks fantastic
we'll take a break we'll have naked a
couple of golf shots here if you'd like
to watch you can on DirecTV the audience
Network channel 239 and the NBC Sports
Network just for the nation out I'm
gonna our medieval Instagram [ __ ] and
almost like a friendly that's a painting
here yeah get in there get in there
thick drop the cup of quick is the
coverage with a quick lesson are that
passable that will be you a very perfect
palette so after watching these guys I
mean I've done did you do that on
purpose
did you do that on purpose
alright properly thumbs up a one yo from
with thumbs up when you write some up
put your right some Tigers stop by I
wanted to give you some advice yeah this
summer
oh look at that it it is where is it
also dismiss this template that enhance
on top keep your eye up keep your eyes
on the ball
what's the biggest mistake that we make
playing like I said as I get a little
alignment and then yes tempos really
important visual iced coffee semi single
ooh you say Louie Louie how nice exactly
look at that Who am I even going the
foot oh good Jordan Street coffee some
Hillier from Antigua Jordan speith yeah
look how nice that one
that's swing Johnny Miller Johnny I'll
tell you Johnny minute numbers Johnny
means we go guys it's just driving me
jerk hitting you go Johnny Miller T
giant after super cut
how about Rocco Mediate never come here
oh you can re Rory McIlroy maybe he has
a lake because Rory Matt if you don't
like him the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]